White House doing damage control after
getting called out by gold star families
over the botched withdrawal from
Afghanistan the president called it a
success but family members of the 13
American Service members killed say he
is lying
do what our son did
be a grown ass man
admit your mistakes
learn from them so that this doesn't
happen ever
ever again call this evacuation a
success as if there should be
celebration it is like a knife in the
heart what kind of disrespect
kind of hatred we would hold lies
give an incomplete reports incorrect
reports
total disrespect
those parents are very upset but the
administration is not offering up an
apology Biden also getting slammed by a
gold star mom for having this tone deaf
reaction
when Joe Biden
our elected president entered the room
when he approached me his words to me
were my my wife Jill and I know how you
feel we lost our son as well and brought
him home in a fog-draped coffin
my heart started beating faster and I
started shaking knowing that their son
died from cancer and they were able to
be by his side
so Jesse I I'm just thinking of the last
topic where in today's world people are
expected to apologize over uh views on
heterosexuality but there's no apology
for one of the worst military disasters
at least in my lifetime and and they're
calling it a success so this is what
politicians are supposed to be good at
right you hire a politician because
you're supposed to cry with a mom
and it's not like the Iraq war or World
War one or two or you know you have an
amazing amount of people dead on your
doorstep these are 13 service members
okay not a lot of people so what you do
is the president is that you cherish
these families and you nurture this
relationship and I'm talking letters
phone calls events you call them on
Thanksgiving you check in with them you
invite them to the White House and it's
a year-long relationship that you now
have with these 13 families
how do I know that you know people don't
think Jesse Waters Humanity no okay it's
the last thing we think about this is an
elemental aspect of the Human Condition
these people died on your watch because
of a mistake that your Administration
made is is the least you could do is
create some sort of bond with these
families yeah so these families now feel
like they're they're their sons and
daughters weren't worthless this guy
checked his watch when the coffins were
coming home on the tarmac this guy has
never really owned up to this mistake I
hate using this analogy but if this had
happened under the Trump Administration
you would have seen every single one of
these gold star family members on every
single show every single Sunday until
the election
that's just the way it is but these
families have been ignored because it
doesn't fit the narrative and it's a
shame and I'm sorry on the president's
behalf but I don't I'm sorry go ahead I
just I don't think that's actually true
and I'll tell you why because I don't
think president Trump would abducted
right okay so you the the so the Biden
people wouldn't have been able to use it
against President Trump because he would
have owned up to it right he would have
held them close he would have done all
the things that you're talking about
make sure their children have
scholarships make sure they have
opportunity take them to want to ride on
Air Force One like whatever it might be
they would have had the relationship so
that would have happened because empathy
is a choice Biden made one right but
what Biden decided to do here was to
blame the Trump Administration yeah that
was they kept saying that well they left
us a mess and that is that is patently
untrue there's and there's so many moral
injuries right now with the veterans who
tried to help so many of the Afghans who
had helped them who spent their life
savings every contact they had they
traveled through Kazakhstan in order to
get there in order to help save these
guys for the ones that we're able to get
here they're now waiting for the state
department to get their act together so
that they can have permanent status so
that they can at least start their lives
and begin here the backlogs is like 80
000 strong so one thing that if the
buying Administration really wanted to
try to do something about this it could
try to fix that but there's really no
indication unfortunately that would be
near this anniversary that that's
happening yeah you know Harold we were
sold in 2020 that Joe was good was this
guy who could was it put a human face on
on uh and and express this empathy but
the smiles the handshakes the hugs all
of this stuff just comes off as phony as
anything because it's always infused
with this weird falsehood and this
confusion of facts what it what do you
make of this why can't he do this
well I think a couple things first after
the Bay of Pigs I thought President
Kennedy summed it up well because most
presidents never take responsibility for
for failures he said that victory has a
hundred fathers and defeat as an orphan
and I've never seen a president come
forward and take full responsibility for
for anything that that's gone wrong
um I feel for these these gold star
families that the pain that that father
uh asking the president to own up to it
it takes a lot for anyone to say that to
the president United States certainly uh
uh an everyday American citizen who
happens to be the father of someone who
gave their life for the country
um
does President Biden have blame
absolutely
uh is he solely to blame for a 20-year
war no uh but he's president now and uh
I think to your point Jesse there
probably was a lot that could have been
done over the last year or so uh to not
only cultivate a relationship uh but to
express
um what we what we would do better in a
situation
um I think when you are inclined to just
blame your predecessor in politics
you're not living up to everything you
should be living up to in any office
this is not directed in any any personal
way towards President Biden but the way
to really to deal with this is to lay
out the plan so we know this will never
happen again wherever we might be in and
if you need to blame president Trump and
others go right ahead and do that but
lay out what we did wrong and what could
be done better as we think about this
going forward for that to happen though
Katie you should have some kind of media
that cares yeah about this so it doesn't
happen again
what just said is true it's like if it
was Trump you'd be having reassessments
and assessments and hearing after
hearing after hearing in this case it's
always when there's something bad that
happens under a Democratic president
it's one and done there's so many
consequences to what has happened here
and the white Administration went out of
their way to sell this as a success they
tried to make it a good PR move to say
it was not just a success but the most
successful airlift in American history
well we're all watching what was
unfolding and then these 13 service
members were killed and now we're seeing
that from the parents and testimony that
they took the SIM cards away and when
John Kirby said that from my perch it
wasn't chaotic right well I guarantee
you those SIM cards from the phones the
people who died showed a very different
story than what he said and the
narrative that the White House has been
trying to push and they haven't
recovered from this this is something
that made President Biden's poll numbers
go down he hasn't recovered from it and
the thing that is really
um just a horrible that Biden just keeps
doing is he keeps equating Beau Biden's
death from cancer which is horrible
awful a lot of us know people who died
from cancer but he equates that to being
killed in combat to grieving parents who
have just had their children killed in
combat and quite frankly it's it's like
a Stolen Valor I mean you're implying
that he was killed in combat when he
wasn't and he's done this to a number of
parents it didn't just happen once it's
happened to at least three sets of them
and so they tried to sell this to
success it isn't and more for the morale
of the military which we continue to
hear a lot about with the Pentagon
because they can't recruit anybody this
of course was a huge moment for them and
when I was in Normandy uh in in June I
sat across the table for dinner with an
Army Ranger and I was just asking him
about his career and he told me he
served 12 tours in Afghanistan
and immediately I knew what that meant
and he was completely broken and this
does not help at all and for them to say
it's a success um it can continue with
that line when clear it wasn't does not
help the country when it comes to
military Readiness all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else